the chances are you've never seen this
boy before but you've seen many like him
his name is Harris Johnny Harris and
he's in the seventh grade at District
two though Johnny himself is a stranger
to you the disease that made him a
[ __ ] is no stranger
it was polio myelitis a communicable
disease
encephalitis Rocky Mountain spotted
fever ringworm
infectious diarrhea murine typhus
malaria influenza communicable diseases
where do they come from and how do they
spread many diseases like tuberculosis
polio myelitis and influenza survived in
man and are spread from person to person
some diseases spread by other means rats
may carry typhus mice may cause
bacillary dysentery mosquitos bring
malaria dengue encephalitis ticks bring
Rocky Mountain fever relapsing fever
flies carry typhoid trachoma
please carry bubonic plague some
diseases spread from contaminated meat
or food raw milk may cause death FIRREA
undulant fever polluted water
schistosomiasis
cholera
every year hundreds of thousands of
people suffer from communicable diseases
and many die unnecessarily from
preventable infections communicable
diseases recognize no boundaries for
they've taken their toll of human life
the world over their control may be a
national problem or it may be regional
involving several states or it may be
local an epidemic might start anywhere
and reach into many states the classic
example is the 1918 influenza pandemic
which was first recognized in Boston and
within a month spread throughout the
entire country today always watchful for
epidemics practicing physicians
constitute the first line of defense but
the responsibility for the prevention of
communicable diseases is vested
primarily in the state and local health
departments which are assisted upon
request by the United States Public
Health Service the communicable disease
center with its headquarters in Atlanta
Georgia serves the nation in field
investigation prevention and control of
communicable diseases in cooperation
with local health agencies all over the
country the communicable disease Center
better known as CDC has established
diagnostic laboratories Applied Research
Projects control operations and field
training centers CDC employs a variety
of professional specialists skilled in
every aspect of communicable diseases
medical epidemiologists veterinary
epidemiologists public health nurses
laboratory technicians parasitologists
entomologists sanitary engineers
statisticians training specialists
and many others who work together to
solve the practical problems and get
results in the fight against
communicable diseases it may be a
problem concerning a section of the
country where year in and year out its
rivers rise to flood out whole towns and
villages the flood subsides leaving in
its wake
billions upon billions of mosquito
larvae and the threat of malaria becomes
obvious once more scientific information
on the subject is discussed and analyzed
decisions are made and one of these is
to design more effective equipment to
combat the dreaded mosquito ground
equipment or air equipment inexpensive
to build cheap to operate but effective
and its effectiveness will depend on
many factors all very familiar to the
engineering mind the type of larvacide
best suited to the problem and how many
gallons per minute will the unit deliver
how large the nozzle how wide the
orifice how much pressure for maximum
effect field test how well does it
perform under actual conditions gallons
per acre distribution width or the swath
size of the droplets so it's the job of
CDC to develop experimentally procedures
materials equipment and to test them
until their effectiveness is established
beyond question the proven techniques
are then demonstrated to the state
health authorities whose personnel are
trained to carry out the programs in
common with medical organizations all
over the world
CDC is trying to solve the riddle of
polio myelitis which kills or paralyzes
thousands of people every year
in the research laboratories it has been
found that where flies have access to
the feces of infected persons the
presence of the virus of poliomyelitis
can be demonstrated in the Flies by
injection into susceptible animals but
our flies and important and frequent
mode of transmission would fly control
reduce the incidence of poliomyelitis
we know now that flies do transmit
another disease which is a very real
public health problem dysentery today
CDC has organized with state and local
health departments a nationwide fly
control program to reduce the incidence
of dysentery yet at one time flies were
only suspected as carriers it has since
been demonstrated that clean flies
exposed to a culture of dysentery
organisms carried these germs in or on
their bodies
if the fly remained on the culture for
only a few seconds and was then placed
on a sterile medium the medium showed
colonies of dysentery organisms after a
period of incubation it was found that
the same sort of transfer occurred when
flies went from feces to food because
these scientific observations strongly
indicated a probable relationship
between dysentery and flies the
development of an experimental program
was decided upon in this case it was
undertaken jointly by the National
Institutes of Health and CDC as the
first step in the program
epidemiologists selected an insanitary
section of town a section that was known
to have a high incidence of dysentery
and where it was also known that there
were many flies
flies would be controlled in one half of
the section but not in the other but to
prove that flies were important carriers
it would have to be shown that the
morbidity and mortality rates of the
controlled area had been appreciably
reduced
for this experimental control program
special tools and equipment were
designed
fly populations were measured identified
and collected for laboratory studies
throughout the controlled and
uncontrolled areas
schoolchildren from both areas were
brought to the clinic rectal swabs were
made so that bacteriologists could
determine the prevalence of Shigella
organisms epidemiologists determined the
amounts of diarrhea morbidity by going
from house to house through both areas
asking housewives if members of their
families had experience diarrhea in the
last 30 days mortality figures were
obtained from the County Health Officer
in the area to be controlled inspections
were made to find the fly breeding areas
by breeding areas were brought under
control by basic sanitation procedures
this experimental program proved that
dysentery could be reduced from 1/3 to
1/2 by fly control
when we view that dysentery could be
reduced by fly control and the
expenditure of public funds was
justified the next step was to
demonstrate to the state's the proven
operational procedures and train their
personnel in the application of these
practices such arrangements are usually
made through CDC regional
representatives when requests for
assistance come from state health
officers family I wonder if you people
could help us we've got ten counties in
this state where the death and sickness
from dysentery especially babies have
always been higher than the rest of the
state yeah I know
most of those counties are in the
low-income areas no garbage disposal
they had sanitation and pack
everything's bad yes
you know we've always wanted to get some
flak control going down there but we
just haven't had anybody that knows how
to organize the program and I see that
it's carried out we don't have any
equipment trucks bulldozers dragline
sprayers we can send you some big power
sprayers but we have the money for
trucks and draglines and things like
that right now we may be able to give
you a little more help later on in the
meantime could you could you work out a
deal with your highway department to use
some of their heavy equipment I think we
ought to be able to work something out
there now about that training course and
flag can fall in at ladder next week
I can't span it my people right now and
be a couple of months before I can get
anybody jet ladder and we want to get
this thing going
since you're going to have a big program
it might be more economical to start the
training program right here in your
state I'll see what I can do with their
banner people so that's fine Sam now
we've got some more training problems
what are we going to do about all of
those technicians that require all the
special courses now you've just got to
help me that's all so CDC trained the
personnel of this state on the proven
methods of fly control and enable them
to set up their own program training is
an important part of the CDC
organization and covers such things as
water supply
Prine pollution sewage
how they
laboratory procedures sanitary
engineering mycotic diseases and many
others training centers are
strategically located throughout the
United States and are attended by state
and local health personnel and students
from many foreign countries
audio-visual aids for training are
planned and produced by CDC
all types of printed material are also
available
training at all levels is carried on in
the diagnosis prevention and control of
communicable diseases CDC is one of the
task forces of the Public Health Service
a reservoir of engineering scientific
and medical knowledge ready to help each
state in its fight against communicable
diseases
today as yesterday the challenge
continues and opportunity is great for
doctors for nurses for scientists and
for many others with the ambition and
with the training to accept that
challenge
you